c'est pas que tu peux plus avancer c'est
que enfin moi dans mon cas après chaque
histoire est différente encore une
histoire différente
on a tous l'impression que à chaque fois
il arrive des drames
en fait je je
c'est très délicat à expliquer c'est
juste que moi aujourd'hui moi dans mon
cas c'est une injustice mais tout le
monde m'a toujours dit là il faut que tu
te fasses tout petit depuis le début
avec ce qui t'arrive fais-toi tout petit
c'est mieux mais non alors on va
rappeler l'affaire
est-ce qu'il y a déjà eu plein de contre
toi déjà dans cette histoire rien jamais
d'accord rien tu n'as jamais été
convoqué par la police quoi que ce soit
suite à cette histoire d'accord suite à
cette histoire
il y a eu une plainte de déposer suite à
cette histoire qui a été parce qu'il en
fait un moment donné comme il y avait
rien dans cette histoire contre moi ni
Victor alors c'est pas de victimes il y
avait une vidéo soi-disant on disait
vidéo la vidéo la vidéo j'avais dit il y
a un an sortez là et que ça sortirait
pas ce que ça n'existe pas ça fait un an
on va rappeler l'histoire toujours
mais l'histoire depuis le début oui oui
il y aurait eu sur une vidéo un moment
où Ilan aurait agressé sexuellement une
mineure cette vidéo on a entendu parler
sur les plateaux je me permets de te
couper mineur ça a été rajouté ça c'est
juste pour faire plaisir dans la vie
dans une vidéo d'interview on dit mineur
et puis après sur plateau TPMP on dit ah
non je pouvais pas savoir si elle était
mineur sauf que tout le monde ils ont
pas retenu ça donc ça veut dire en fait
c'est mineur c'est juste on va rajouter
mineure parce que c'est une circonstance
aggravante et ça va être bien ça j'ai
utilisé le conditionnel attention je
parle pas de toi je parle de ce qui
s'est passé voilà mais déjà il y a pas
de vidéo
comme j'ai expliqué et je l'ai redis je
l'ai eu cette vidéo d'ailleurs on ne l'a
pas trouvé honnêtement moi je dis hein
je l'ai cherché on l'a cherché avec les
personnes dans cette vidéo on ne l'a pas
trouvé c'est parti d'une rumeur d'une
vidéo aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir
chaque chose dans notre milieu quand il
y a quelque chose ça sort faut arrêter
de dire peut-être ça sort moi je suis
j'ai pas des pouvoirs magiques quand il
y a une vidéo d'un truc il y avait une
histoire de télé je pars au mieux
écouter en plus c'était des amis
mais quand il y a une vidéo ça sort faut
arrêter de croire tu peux pas cacher
quand c'est quelque part ça sort un
moment donné moi ça a fait quand même le
tour il y a rien alors
on va dire Ilan il est super fort il a
réussi à cacher la vidéo ok bon je suis
fort il y a quand même pas de victimes
pas de vidéo pas de formation oui
diffamation accusation calomnieuse je
suis accompagné d'un avocat comment tu
as vécu toute cette histoire c'est un
cauchemar pour toi
le lundi j'étais Ilan
je vous dis la vérité j'avais tout
j'avais tout ce que j'y rêvé dans ma vie
je venais de me fiancer avec eux une
fille
on avait enfin pu concrétiser notre
histoire à la télé ça allait sortir
après
j'avais décidé de me ranger à ce
moment-là parce que ça y est j'avais
décidé d'arrêter la télé donc j'avais
dit dans mon programme télé c'est ma
dernière télé c'est terminé j'avais
d'autres projets
je devais signer dans un label de
musique je devais signer une série aussi
un petit connu en France c'est pas le
rôle principal mais c'est un mot sympa
je démarre mon propre TV show à moi
j'étais en discussion avec ça le lundi
c'était tous ces projets là le mardi il
y avait plus rien
et en plus je me faisais insulter par la
France entière ma famille se faisait
insulter par la France entière
menacé de mort menace antisémite j'ai le
droit tout moi tout tout tout on va te
crever chez toi ça le Juif on va venir
violer ta mère on va violer tes petits
frères j'ai eu le droit à tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer et ça fait un an que ça
dure
ça fait un an que ça dure moi en fait je
suis fort les réseaux sociaux j'ai
appris à vivre avec j'ai appris
encaisser les bad buzz et ça c'est pas
un problème sauf que quand ça touche à
la famille c'est autre chose
ma mère ça fait 8 mois 4 ans peut plus
mon père il a des soucis de santé dû au
stress mes parents ils habitent en
Martinique hein là-bas ils ont un bon
job ils ont pas de problème dans leur
vie par contre moi je suis devenu un
problème
malgré moi et en fait ce qui est pas
normal en réalité c'est que il y a plus
de justice en vrai c'est c'est moi
jumeau ma condamné c'est moi j'étais
condamné mais par médiatiquement parlant
j'ai pas été condamné par la justice il
y a rien et il y aura jamais rien donc
en fait aujourd'hui la vérité je dois
m'y faire c'est que je serai sali à vie
peut-être qu'il y a des gens qui auront
toujours un petit doute oui mais il y
avait pas de preuve oui mais il y avait
pas de fille si vous gagnez votre procès
pour diffamation là vous serez peut-être
blanchi à ce moment-là et pourquoi parce
que si jamais on voit que tout ça est
tout ça se passe pas comme ça en France
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont dire les gens oui
mais il y avait pas de preuve donc elle
a pas pu trouver ce qu'il a dit
c'est pas alors Ilan ton surnom c'est
Ilan le Charroux je pense c'est à cause
du torse ça le Charo ça veut dire voilà
ouais mais c'est ce qui m'a créé mais
c'est ce qui m'a créé c'est à dire que
je vais pas renier qui je suis encore
une fois on m'a dit alors attention j'ai
pris une claque dans la gueule pendant
un an c'est pas que j'ai changé c'est
j'ai évolué c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné
bon ben voilà tu te fais rattraper par
la réalité qui fait que j'ai joué de ce
personnage qui était moi 80% oui j'étais
un séducteur et oui j'ai profité et bien
et je vais pas mentir mais ça fait pas
de moi un violeur ou un pointeur ou
pédophile ils ont rajouté mais c'est des
dingueries aujourd'hui je pense que pour
un homme il y a pas pire comme insulte
sur terre je vais quand je quand c'est
arrivé j'étais quand je vous dis au fond
du trou Marco était Marco m'avait vu à
l'époque tu te rappelles j'étais au fond
du trou je me la raconter
de rigoler je vais un rendez-vous chez
Magali ça fait plaisir les potes comme
toi
les mecs comme ça dans la dans comment
ils sont je rigole quand tu as rien fait
normalement tu dois pas être malheureux
désolé moi j'ai rien fait même la radio
escroquerie je l'ai pas faite pour moi
donc je suis bien je suis clair je suis
clair dans mes bottes j'ai pas de
problème c'est quand tu as fait tu as
peur donc quand tu as pas fait tu as pas
peur quand j'étais le voir je le
connaissais pas Magali me l'a présenté
j'ai vu
les garçons les premiers baisers
son lit non en dessous son lit pas dire
un mot et puis j'ai remarqué quelque
chose que ça meuf qui avait ta meuf à
l'époque elle a pris le dessus sur lui
tu as compris c'est à cause de toi tout
ça
mais j'ai rien fait si on veut que tu
remontes le moral des gens
alors vraiment tu es quand même
quelqu'un qui
grâce à toi
la différence après le mec il est arrivé
en forme d'un seul coup il a fait une
connerie la meuf c'est elle reprend lui
il est là il est timide et toi mais
j'arrive pas à comprendre là tu reviens
dans les réseaux et en fait j'ai oublié
je vais te poser une question
qui travaille là-bas mais là normalement
tu reviens dans les réseaux mais en fait
dans tous les 5 minutes parce que j'ai
jamais quitté les réseaux parce que
j'essaie de garder la face mais le
problème aujourd'hui il est il est où
je suis sur les réseaux j'ai une
audience incroyable et ma communauté je
les remercie tous les jours ils m'ont
soutenu la meuf qui parle les gens
présumé
quelqu'un a dit j'ai vu Ilan dans une
vidéo
c'est même pas quelqu'un qui a dit il
m'a fait
j'ai vu quelqu'un dans une vidéo est le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
ça c'est que vous savez comment ça
marche le réseau quand on veut
elles sont décoller on dirait chevalier
Laspalès depuis
aujourd'hui les réseaux comment ça se
déjà moi la télé je vous dis la vérité
j'ai essayé de me battre parce que moi
je suis quelqu'un de super optimiste
donc j'ai toujours cru que Ben à un
moment donné ça se passerait que même si
je gagne mon procès admettons ça se
passe bien et je puisse reprendre ma vie
en fait juste reprendre ma vie mais on
m'a remis à la réalité en me disant Ilan
je te dis la vérité avec ce qui s'est
passé oublie ta carrière la télé s'est
terminée
en fait je vais vous dire mettez
moi c'est ce que j'aime faire c'est à
dire que c'est pas une question d'argent
on en est plus là j'y ai perdu
aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux
c'est fini je gagne plus ma vie et que
ça ça fait un an mais en un an on
Ferrari à Cannes quoi
c'est la vérité alors bon
ah ouais non mais franchement non mais
c'est sympa de t'avoir non c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est quoi cette histoire vous
allez comprendre
en plus tu faisais le beau gosse
tu vois Android
comme ça sur la tête de Anaï il est
sorti comment tu vas marquer ça va dans
ma caisse il a pas eu un problème
celui-là
à tête de Barbie non ils vont vite avec
l'argent je vais t'expliquer ce qui se
passe c'est que moi dans dans mon
malheur c'est que toutes mes années télé
j'ai compris moi j'ai pas dépensé mon
argent j'ai payé mes impôts et j'ai pas
dépensé ce qui fait que ça m'a permis de
survivre après survivre en Ferrari
[Applaudissements]
au mois d'août il voulait pas me faire
de prix mon mari c'est 2005 la chambre
faire 2004-19 il est content que tu sois
venu
non la vraie vérité c'est que non la
vraie vérité c'est que j'avais déjà moi
j'avais beaucoup économisé mais tu sais
un moment donné tu as beau être riche si
demain tu as source de revenus principal
s'arrête ça va vite parce que quand tu
débutes mais non mais c'est la vérité je
non mais pour de vrai non mais parce que
vous rigolez mais je suis passé de tout
à zéro non mais vraiment alors
tu peux enfin je sais pas quand tu as de
l'argent c'est bien mais quand tout
s'arrête ça va très vite dans l'autre
sens
la chose que non la chance que j'ai eu
l'argent
tu fais travailler il critiquer j'ai eu
la chance de de pouvoir acheter de
l'immobilier ce qui fait que bah
tu avais voilà tu avais un petit ça
c'est bien alors mais attendez parce que
ça dure quatre cinq mois et après un
moment donné moi j'ai des prêts j'ai des
prêts sur la tête je sais pas j'ai pas
tout payé comme ça il y a plein de gens
qui ont des pressent sur la tête un
moment donné c'est non mais oui mais
quand tu n'as plus d'argent pour payer
tu es prêt bah à un moment donné où
travailler ou revendre ce que tu as
acheté une partie de ce que tu as
achetées
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour m'en sortir
de relou là
psychologique aujourd'hui en fait je
veux juste que ça s'arrête parce que
vous savez dès que j'arrive à sortir un
petit peu la tête de l'eau il y a
quelqu'un qui vient et qui me remet la
tête sous l'eau c'est ça le problème tu
as pas d'histoire il y a pas de victime
quelle histoire que tu as mais c'est
juste il a aussi pour le coup en fait il
y a un blogueur je vous dis je vous
disais exemple quand vous avez annoncé
mon nom vous voyez là ce titre à côté de
mon nom je peux plus
accusé d'agression ce titre je l'ai
entendu tellement de fois en un an que
je peux plus en fait je mérite pas ça
c'est dur c'est en fait ce titre là
pourquoi pourquoi aujourd'hui mon nom
il doit être associé à ça je n'y arrive
plus en fait c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est pas une question
d'argent vous savez je vous dis à vérité
je me suis retrouvé on en rigole oui
j'avais heureusement j'avais bien gagné
ma vie dans ma j'ai eu bien gagner ma
vie mais quand je me suis retrouvé à
terre en fait il fallait que je trouve
réellement une solution très rapidement
parce que sinon j'aurais aussi tout
perdu ce que j'avais construit ces
années-là Ilan et c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre et mais dans un état où tu es
pas bien tu as tout le monde qui à terre
dans ta famille alors oui je comprends
faut retourner travailler mais
psychologiquement
c'était tes parents c'est ton père qui a
ton père qui a fait mon père a eu un
souci de santé grave pour pour ce qui
s'est passé grave
l'équivalent d'un AVC c'est ça à cause
du stress mes grands-parents je vais
tourner avec vous je les préserve de
tout ça ils comprennent pas il m'appelle
Sabrina ouais ouais ça va t'inquiète
c'est pour la télé t'inquiète c'est pour
le show nana je les préserve de ça parce
que je sais pas quoi leur dire ils ont
75 ans mes grands-parents ils méritent
pas ça
je suis un petit peu leur bien sûr
ça détruit ma famille mes petits frères
mes petits frères ils ont 19 et 21 ans
ils ont des ils vont au travail ils ont
une vie active ouais ton frère Noémie
parfois on sortait des gens dans la rue
c'est en fait il y a pas pire que il y a
pas pire comme accusation pour un homme
que de ce que d'un truc que tu as pas
fait et vous savez quoi allez-vous
défendre et ben je défie quiconque qui
comme dans le premier si demain je dis
moi j'ai vu une vidéo de Cyril en train
de violer Gilles Verdez
Cyril j'ai la vidéo je veux la voir la
vidéo je suis première boule
aujourd'hui
personne ne veut te faire travailler
tout au monde te tourne le dos enfin
c'est fini moi ce que j'aime le faire
c'est la télé c'est le chaud parce que
j'aime faire rire les gens parce que
c'est en fait c'est je m'étais trouvé
vous savez chaque homme dans sa ville a
une carrière moi je m'étais trouvé moi
c'était je me considérais considère
comme un artiste j'aime tout faire je
suis pas chanteur mais j'ai fait de la
musique je suis pas acteur mais j'ai
commencé à faire un petit cinéma et
j'avais un avenir parce que Ben malgré
tout je plaisais et ça commençait enfin
à aboutir à quelque chose tout ça mais
au final plus rien et quand aujourd'hui
j'ai un de mes producteurs qui me dit là
je suis la vérité c'est terminé
alors qu'il y a des candidats qui ont
fait pire et qui sont encore à la télé
mais ça c'est notre histoire et à la
limite ça me regarde pas mais je trouve
ça injuste
projet du coup produisez
c'est que là aujourd'hui ses parents ses
parents aujourd'hui peuvent pas sortir
dans la rue son père il est il est sa
famille elle est allé au bout de sa vie
Ilan regarde-le dans quelle taille je
vois il y a des vidéos il pleure toute
la journée c'est pas aussi facile que et
puis même pour faire tu sais pour pour
faire tes projets il faut quand même
avoir une sécurité quand un quand
l'argent qui rentre pour manger vous
voyez ce que je veux dire et tu peux pas
aller dire et je vais faire un projet
avant je pouvais faire des tournages des
6 dessins plein de projets où j'ai
investi moi même dans ma carrière et
maintenant je peux plus le faire parce
que Ben
je peux plus le faire alors qu'est-ce
que je fais quand tu te retrouves je me
suis retrouvé dos au mur ou à un moment
donné je vous dis la vérité à un moment
donné c'était compliqué je pouvais plus
payer ce que je mon train de vie ne
suivait plus j'ai créé trois boîtes pour
m'en sortir je suis pas je suis tout le
monde pense que je suis un branleur
c'est la vérité j'en suis pas je bosse
vraiment réellement j'ai monté trois
sociétés et pas des sociétés on dit
ouais j'ai fait non non une société de
transport j'entends d'ouvrir un
restaurant à Nice à un Dubaï et j'ai une
société d'achat de revente de montre ah
c'est bien et la moitié est en France où
je paye mes impôts en France
alors tout ça m'a permis de bouger on va
dire les fesses et de créer tout ça mais
en réalité j'avais pas besoin de ça et
moi ce que j'aimais c'est pas ça moi ce
que j'aimais c'est ma vie et sauf que
pour moi en fait vous êtes enfin ce qui
vous arrive c'est la métastase de la
téléréalité c'est à dire que comme c'est
un truc de de classe de buzz exactement
il fallait mettre le curseur de plus en
plus loin pour faire parler de soi mais
en fait les filles elles font elles vont
elles vont peut-être dire quelque chose
d'immonde peut-être quelque chose qui
est faux pour vous mettre dans la sauce
parce qu'en fait c'est que comme ça
aujourd'hui que la télé réalité peut
exister et donc malgré tout je pense
qu'on arrive à la fin d'un système et
peut-être que c'est une chance pour vous
parce que vous allez pouvoir peut-être
vous extirper ce truc là et faire autre
chose que ce que cette merde là quoi je
pense que faire c'est peut-être un mal
pour un bien alors oui mais faire autre
chose c'est pas un problème
vous savez même mon propre programme
télé j'ai pensé dix fois je le finance
c'est pas un souci ça c'est pas un souci
tu vends la Ferrari au pire voilà
je sais que mais non c'est pas ça le
problème la réalité c'est pas ça c'est
que mon nom il est sali et c'est ça qui
est horrible c'est même pas on oublie
tout le reste juste mon nom il est sali
et ça c'est pas acceptable est-ce que tu
auras à dire à tes parents ce soir Ilan
à tes proches à ta grand-mère qu'est-ce
que tu dors direct
pour ceux qui savent pas vous compreniez
moi je me suis appelé Ilan c'était haut
sur les réseaux parce que je m'étais dit
quand j'ai commencé à la télé bon je
suis quelqu'un de très maladroit si un
jour je fais une connerie peut-être ça
peut péter donc c'est bien qu'on
reprenne pas mon nom qu'on s'il y a une
connerie comme celle-ci que ça soit Ilan
c'était haut et pas castronomovo
quand il y a eu cette histoire les
médias sont allés chercher mon nom de
famille
ce que les gens savent pas et pourquoi
ça ça m'a réellement détruit
moi j'étais adopté à l'âge d'un an et
demi
ma mère m'a eu toute seule
mon père a rencontré ma mère est tombé
amoureux de ma mère et moi en même temps
il m'a reconnu donc il m'a donné son nom
je pense qu'il y a que les personnes qui
vivent ça qui peuvent comprendre ce que
c'est de recevoir de l'amour de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas ton son mon père
c'est mon père
et j'ai tout voulu toujours fait en
sorte de vouloir le rendre fier de moi
de faire honneur au nom qui m'a donné
et d'avoir malgré moi parce que c'est un
peu de ma faute malgré tout parce que
c'est moi qui a décidé d'être médiatisé
et ils ont rien demandé j'ai sali un peu
son nom
un peu j'ai sali son nom et aujourd'hui
c'est la chose que je pourrais dire
c'est je m'excuse auprès de mon papa
d'avoir fait ça parce que c'était
vraiment pas voulu et
mes parents ils ont jamais eu de doute
sur qui j'étais sur ce que je faisais
parce que j'ai même entendu dans les
médias que mes parents doutaient de moi
mes parents ils savent très bien qui je
suis mes parents ils ont connu quasiment
toutes mes copines et on a eu
ils savent qui je suis que je suis
incapable de faire du mal de ce genre de
mal à une femme et comme aujourd'hui les
gens ils ont tout mélangé il a un Charo
tu trompes tu respectes pas les femmes
parce que c'est vrai quand tu trompes tu
respectes pas ta femme
ça fait pas de moi un violeur
faut pas tout répondre aux gens qui
disent que la fille qui n'a pas témoigné
c'est parce qu'elle a peur
de quoi
demain vous savez quand un exemple il y
a une fille qui a porté plainte suite à
tout ça parce que une personne la
poussée à le faire
j'évite de dire les noms pourquoi parce
que j'ai pas envie je suis dans la
procédure toute la journée j'ai pas
envie de retourner là-dedans pour
diffamation etc cette fille elle a porté
plainte
je suis pas au-dessus de la justice 7
mois d’enquête une confrontation 15
personnes interrogées classées sans
suite mais classer sans suite pas pour
manque de preuve classer sans suite
parce que ce qu'on m'a reproché c'est
infraction non caractérisée ça veut dire
que même si je l'avais fait je l'ai pas
fait
mais même si je l'avais fait c'est pas
une agression sexuelle donc limite à un
moment donné j'ai été tellement
tellement désespéré j'allais dire mais
alors traitez-moi de gros porc si vous
voulez si vous voulez la croire vous les
croire ok vous c'est votre je l'ai pas
fait mais si vous voulez croire
croyez-le mais faites moi le gros pas
mais pas de violeur ou pas d'agresseur
ou pas de trucs comme ça à la limite
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais
faut se rendre compte toute la journée
après un an et les blogueurs ils en
remettent une couche tout le temps tout
le temps et il a écarté des beaux et
Ilan boycotté et ilanne si c'est
insupportable à vivre c'est
insupportable parce que tout le temps
dans la sauce pour cette histoire de
merde où j'ai pas mérité ça et les gens
me disent là tu devrais te faire tout
petit mais non je vais me faire tout
petit si j'ai fait quelque chose vous
avez ma parole d'homme sur la tête de
mes grands-parents que si j'avais fait
quelque chose j'aurais coupé tous les
réseaux fini basta je me fais tout petit
comme ça si un jour il y a un problème
bon bah ça fera pas de bruit mais je
vais pas me faire tout petit parce que
j'ai rien fait donc s'il faut que je le
répète pendant 5 ans pendant 10 ans
pendant 20 ans je le répéterai pendant
20 ans je n'ai rien fait de ces
histoires de merde
et c'est une vérité et aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que quand quelqu'un dit
et bah tu as fait Ilan est-ce que tu as
fait un tentative de suicide
je vais vous dire la vérité j'ai eu un
moment j'ai eu un vrai vrai coup de mou
ouais j'ai eu un vrai coup de mou
sur une accumulation sur une
accumulation c'est un moment donné
je peux aller bien 5 heures dans la
journée mais je vais voir une seule
petite insulte ça va me
ça va me tuer parce que en fait c'est
pas celle-là c'est tout ce qu'il y a eu
avant moi je vais te dire pour résumer
ton histoire et je rejoins Géraldine
maillet on le voit un tout ceux qui font
de la télé-réalité qui font des réseaux
sociaux on les voit ce sont les plus
malheureux du monde et c'est vrai que je
vous dis c'est un fléau incroyable je le
redis pour moi c'est le plus grand fléau
du moment pour les pour les jeunes c'est
ils finissent tous mal ils sont tous
malheureux j'en connais pas un qui est
heureux à un moment donné quoi qu'il
arrive ils sont malheureux ils sont dans
le système c'est ça les bras et et je te
le dis mais Géraldine moi tu sors un peu
de ces conneries limite c'est peut-être
une bonne nouvelle parce que je te dis
c'est un drame ça et on en parlait voilà
on voit il y a plein de gens qui disent
voilà les réseaux sociaux en fait
c'est que ça fait le roi des gens je
suis désolé voilà ouais mais faut pas
écouter les rumeurs c'est à dire qu'en
quelques sur les il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se disent
les blogueurs
aujourd'hui deux éventuellement votre
malheur vous voyez ce que je veux dire
bah en fait le système est complètement
perversé complètement vicieux en fait
c'est la c'est la fin du système en fait
donc en fait c'est je vous dis la vérité
avec tout ce que j'ai vécu hein et je
pense que je suis une personne bien
placé pour dire ce qui est bon ou pas
sur la téléréalité
oui il y a eu des drames oui il y a eu
des choses très graves et j'en suis la
preuve mais il y a aussi du bon
vous savez non mais je suis à prendre
que la moitié il y a aussi du bon moi je
vous dis la vérité la production avec
laquelle j'ai le plus travaillé
ils ont aussi intervenu dans mon
éducation c'est qui la production moi
j'ai beaucoup de bossé avec banjay c'est
une belle boîte et il faut savoir une
chose c'est que je vous le dis quand
j'ai commencé j'avais 23 ans je parlais
mal je suis à toi
mais pour vous dire un exemple non parce
que c'est important
non mais c'est important moi quand j'ai
commencé la télé j'ai pas honte de dire
que je parlais mal je pouvais dire des
insultes des trucs mais croyez pas qu'on
est parcadré moi combien de fois on aime
dire Ilan ça ici il y a pas de ça tu
dois parler correctement tu dois
respecter tu dois faire ci faut pas
croire qu'on est la solution je l'aime
pour que ça s'arrête on est leurs
enfants
marie-toi je te promets que ça va
s'arrêter
là non parce que la vérité c'est que
pour et Paris toi Daniel Moreau
[Rires]
on se
calme hein
truc en fait non c'est qu'il faut
comprendre c'est pour vous dire faut et
c'est vraiment important faut pas
écouter juste les rumeurs en fait si
quelqu'un parle d'une chose sans preuve
il faut pas l'écouter parce que oui il y
a du vrai mais il y a aussi beaucoup
Géraldine c'est c'est les réseaux
sociaux c'est vraiment c'est ça c'est la
télé merci merci là en tout cas d'être
venu ce soir ça va
en tous les cas il a raison sur le
dernier point le dernier point c'est que
les réseaux sociaux font beaucoup de
balles même moi je reçois des textos des
fois il me dit comme ça mais un texto
allô ouais ça va toi ouais ça va te
faire [ __ ] ça c'est moi
mais il a enfin bref je veux juste voilà
mais aussi et c'est important de le dire
il y a pas que du mauvais alors oui la
télé aujourd'hui c'est compliqué mais il
y a vraiment pas que du mauvais il y a
aussi des super bon exemple mais le
problème c'est que jamais personne on en
parle jamais des bons exemples mais pour
pour un bon exemple on a notre mauvais
donc voilà